rape is rape whether it's committed by a
stranger in a dark alley or by an
intimate partner in a working
relationship it's rape
whether it's committed by an indigent
person or man of immense power prestige
and privilege rape is rape whether the
survivor reports within an hour within a
year or perhaps never it's rape despite
the complicated dynamics of power and
consent after an assault it's rape
even if there is no some physical
evidence and even if it happened a long
time ago this is the new landscape for
survivors of sexual assault in America I
believe and this is a new day it's a new
day because Harvey Weinstein has finally
been held accountable for crimes he
committed the women who came forward
courageously and that great risk made
that happen
Weinstein is a vicious serial sexual
predator who used his power to threaten
rape assault trick humiliate and
silences victims he has been found
guilty of criminal sexual act in the
first degree and will face on that count
a state prison sentence
of no less than five years and up to 25
years to the jurors I want to thank the
jurors for their service and careful
attention their verdict turned the page
in our justice system on men like Harvey
Weinstein I want to say thank you to the
assistant district attorneys paralegals
and analysts who worked on this case
including Maxine Rosenthal Kevin Wilson
Shannon Goldberg Harry Dunne John Erwin
ELISA Moreno Andy Clark Danny Mejia Cruz
Stephanie littell and Emily Hogan and
especially to Harriet Galvin Megan haast
and Joanie Lucy Orban who conducted a
terribly difficult and meticulous
investigation
and performed masterly a trial under the
brightest of spotlights and finally to
the survivors of Harvey Weinstein io and
we all owe an immense debt to you who
had the courage beyond measure to speak
your story to the world to this
courtroom at great personal risk and in
great personal pain so those of us who
were privileged to be in the courtroom
when they testified you know what I mean
these survivors weren't just brave they
were heroic words can't describe
adequately the sacrifices the survivors
made to pursue justice Weinstein with
his manipulation his resources his
attorneys his publicists and his spies
did everything he could to silence the
survivors but they refused to be silent
they spoke from their hearts and they
were heard they were heard by
Weinstein's other survivors and by
sexual predators all over the world they
sacrificed their privacy and
self-protection knowing better than
anyone the extent of Weinstein's power
manipulation retribution and abuse to
them I would say you broke silence to
hold him accountable and believe me when
I say that because you have done so a
generation of sexual assault survivors
and all of us heard your every word